Anh không thể gặp bố bạm nha không thể muốn dậy
không thể phúc phải mô để không phải hai để không phải bà để không phải mô để
Đại như vậy là ta đã biết
Ờ, tôi ăn thấy đã
Chịm cho cách nhìn trên gồm thì
Chúc cái dào đậm của bạm nha không phải muốn dậy
Sát nệ, phải thời gian bài nó yêu cầu bình của lợp
thời gian bài nó yêu cầu bình của lợp nạ không phải hai đầy
Nhưng bạn chỉ em nào vui chỉ thấy
Thôi ra mặng một lợp chú kể
Kể thấy ra mặng một lợp chú kể
Đại, bởi vì một chú kể nó ngon nạ
Bởi vì lợp chú kể sẽ là
Hai anh, bởi em để xuống ở hớt
Tình độ hà màng không phải hai
Mẹ, không phải hai mẹ
Bởi màng không phải ngon mẹ
Cái gì em dá là, cái gì lúc bắt đầu đời anh
Để lúc bắt đầu bắt đầu bắt đầu đời
Nó thái gì chỉ, cái màn lâu
Bắt mi đình bị chỉ biết
Nó một anh
Lợp đình bị chỉ biết một bắt mi đình
B bị chỉ có bản thêm một anh lâu đàn hải
Cứ gọi